hace 70 años que los humanos lograron la
primera Ascensión al Everest el
neozelandés y el nepalín Sign sherpa se
convirtieron en los primeros en llegar a
la cima de la montaña más alta del mundo
el 29 de mayo de 1953 actualmente
cientos de personas escalan el pico de
8.849 metros cada año y la excursión de
ocho días al campamento base del Everest
sigue siendo una de las más populares de
nepal entre decenas de miles de turistas
al año para los lugareños la popularidad
de alegraste es una cuestión de
subsistencia en muchos hogares tres
generaciones han encontrado empleo en el
alpinismo el trabajo no está exento de
riesgos pero es mucho más lucrativo que
la agricultura o el pastoreo de jacks un
guía experimentado puede ganar hasta
Diez mil dólares en tres meses varias
veces la renta media anual del país el
veterano guía de montaña por batashi
sherpa nació en una aldea a unos diez
kilómetros del campamento base creció
viendo a su padre y a sus tías ir a la
montaña trabajar y pronto se unió a
ellos en expediciones y escalado el
Everest 21 veces antes de jubilarse
han cambiado muchas cosas antes sólo
había unas pocas expediciones pero ahora
hay muchas cada año
Eso significa un aumento de los ingresos
ayudado a mejorar el estilo de vida aquí
mientras la comunidad montañera
celebrada El Aniversario número 70 de la
conquista del Everest también se
enfrentan a la creciente preocupación
por el cambio climático los lugareños
dicen que ya están sintiendo el impacto
de deshielo de los glaciares y de un
clima cada vez más impredecible